هل انتم جاهزون للعوده الى ايام الابيض
والاسود التجوال في اروقه معرض العراق
الدولي للكتاب سيقودنا الى الزمن القديم
لنرى هل لا زالت القاهره تكتب وبيروت تنشر
وبغداد تقرا ام ان الامر تغير اليوم
ولمعرفه ذلك ما علينا سوى ان نتجول بين
صفحات الكتب وسطورها فتعالوا معي
[موسيقى]
هذه السنه المعرض يحمل اسم المفكر هذه
العلوي وبطبعه الحال هذه العلوي مفكر من
من يعني من زمن الخمسينات والستينات وهذا
الزمن هو الزمن الابيض والاسود اذا اضافه
الى ذلك المدى ارادت من هذه الثمامه ان
تعيد للعراقيين شيء من تراثهم وتعيد
التفكير بهذا التراث الغني ثقافيه وفكيا
واجتماعيا
وبالتالي يعني تعطي الانطباع ما بين
القديم والجديد في في هذه المرحله
يعني مدينه وهي حاضره ثقافيه هي تكتب هي
تقرا هي تطبع بجوز احنا شويه تاخرنا في
الفتره معينه من تاريخ العراق السياسي
فعلا انه يعني معروف الظروف الجميله ولكن
مجرد ما صار تغيير بغداد تعمل كل شيء تعمل
ثقافه هي تصنعها وهي تنتجها وهي تصدرها
[موسيقى]
العراقيون اليوم سالنا رواد المعرض عن ذلك
كثيره سياسه اجتماع ثقافه ادب لكن لا حظ
بالدورتين الاخيره كتب كثير عن موضوع
التنميه البشريه همم ما اعرف يعني ترد
الاستفهام عن هذا الموضوع يجوز مرتبط
بالتغير والتكنولوجيا اللي حاصله تغير
طريقه التفكير عند الانسان عند الشباب
محب للادب العربي القديم
قله في هذا الجانب لذلك عندي خيارات اخرى
الادب الحديث بان ابحث بين ضمن الادبين
اجد نفسي من ساق الى قضايا ثقافيه اخرى
كان تكون تاريخيه كانت تكون جغرافيه
يعني من زمان اميل الى كتب
القراءه الادبيه اللي تشمل الروايات سواته
العربيه او العالميه
وكذلك اقرا دوامين الشعر يعني اليوم نحن
بدار النشر عنا تشكيله كتب عام يعني عندي
من كل الكتب اللي مطلوبه
بمشاركتنا العديده بمعارض
هون بالعراق
عنده طلب واقبال شديد على الكتب وطلباتهم
متنوعه في منهم المهتم بالاشياء الادبيه
منهم مهتم بالاشاره كلاسيكيات في حتى طلب
على الروايات واكثر الكتب العلميه والكتب
الدينيه
وتضمن المعرض العديد من الفعاليات
الثقافيه الاخرى كنداوات الادب وجلسات
اجتماعيه واخرى سياسيه فضلا عن عروض فنيه
في مجالات مختلفه من الفنون والموسيقى
زينب صباح العربيه بغداد